hi I'm Rachel and I'm a tasty producer
today I'm gonna share with you some of
my favorite tips and tricks for finding
vegan options when I go out to eat one
cuisine that has a lot of vegan options
is Chinese food look for veggie
dumplings eggplant with garlic sauce
tofu with mixed vegetables rice and
veggie spring rolls instead of egg rolls
you'll want to watch out for eggs and
fried Rice's or in noodles like lo mein
and fish or oyster sauce used in sauces
or soups
I love ordering Chinese because there
are so many sauces and flavor profiles
to try which can make tofu and
vegetables feel like a totally different
dish every time another great option is
middle-eastern food my go-to is here our
hummus falafel Israeli salad baba
ghanoush tabbouleh and pita bread you'll
want to look out for yogurt which is
used in two Zeki sauce and feta which is
commonly used in salads one tip is to
substitute tahini which is made from
sesame seeds for two Zeki to drizzle on
falafel wraps and platters
I love middle-eastern food because it's
a great place to take a big group of
friends where there will be something
for everyone one of my favorite cuisines
for vegan options is Indian food some
great choices are eggplant with potatoes
chana masala rice dosas filled with
potatoes or lentils non-dairy sauces and
chutneys papadum and samosas and pakoras
here you'll want to avoid ghee which is
a clarified butter and typically used to
make naan bread cream or yogurt which
can be found in curries and sauces and
paneer which is a type of cheese some
tips here are to substitute papadum for
naan bread and if there's a dish you
want to try that contains cream or
yogurt ask your server if it's possible
to substitute coconut milk and they
might be able to accommodate you I love
Indian food because a lot of the dishes
are inherently vegetarian or vegan so
there are tons of options to choose from
another cuisine that is usually a safe
bet is Mexican food here I like to get
rice and beans salsa guac and tortilla
chips and veggie burritos or tacos just
be sure to check that the rice and beans
weren't cooked in
or beef broth and make sure to omit any
cheese or sour cream from any of your
dishes one tip is to substitute
guacamole for cheese and sour cream on a
burrito to replace that creaminess even
if you have to make a few substitutions
it's usually pretty easy to find vegan
options at a Mexican restaurant and
personally as long as I have guac I'm a
happy camper next up is Thai food I'll
usually get pad CU with tofu and veggies
Thai red curry papaya salad and
sometimes if they have it a vegan
coconut broth based soup you have to be
careful with Thai food because a lot of
dishes do contain fish sauce oyster
sauce and shrimp paste so ask your
server if those can be omitted
while rice noodles don't contain egg egg
is very common in pad Cu and pad thai so
make sure to ask to have it removed
while fish sauce is prevalent in Thai
food there are restaurants that don't
include it so I would just call the
restaurant ahead of time to be safe so
Italian food is when things start to get
a little trickier but I'm gonna show you
how you can still make it work I'll
usually get a veggie pizza without the
cheese pasta with marinara sauce
bruschetta and mixed olives your biggest
obstacles here will be cheese which is
in basically everything egg which may be
in some fresh pastas and you just want
to make sure that the tomato sauce
wasn't cooked with any meat but that
being said Italian food can be
surprisingly vegan friendly and don't
knock pizza without cheese until you try
it last up we have our most difficult
category the steak house here side
dishes are your friends look for sides
of roasted or steamed veggies rice pilaf
or baked potatoes the biggest ingredient
you'll want to avoid here well besides
the steak is butter so ask if the sides
are cooked in it and if you're able to
substitute oil so you're not just eating
a sad baked potato another option is to
ask your server if the kitchen can
prepare you a vegan friendly dish using
ingredients from the menu like pasta and
vegetables and if worst comes to worst
remember there's always fries and salad
while eating vegan at a steak house
isn't the ideal situation with a little
creative
you can still enjoy a tasty meal so the
dishes I mentioned tend to be vegan
friendly but keep in mind that every
restaurant is different
so always double-check with your server
to see how a dish is prepared and if any
of this felt too restrictive to you just
do the best that you can the important
thing to remember is that when you ask
for vegan options it lets restaurants
know there's a demand for them and
they'll start including them in their
menus more and more finding being in
options when you go out to eat might
seem difficult at first but with a
little practice it's totally doable
whether it's substituting an ingredient
or getting creative with the menu
there's almost always a vegan option out
there
[Music]
you
[Applause]